i think it's from the age of like
16 i just suffered
a lot of trauma until i was
40. you know literally
uh you know violence and death and
people dying and [ __ ] cancer and
alcoholism and addiction and just just
and i got very good at
just
laughing and smiling and let's do
another joke yeah um you know let's
let's just let's keep going let's just
it'll be fine you know and you kind of
get
you kind of get good at pushing it down
and ignoring it you know
um not realizing that it's it doesn't
for me it didn't go away you know it
just
built up and built up and built up and
then
you know
it got to a point a few years ago it's
like i i don't think i can
i don't think i can live like this
anymore as a as a human i
it just felt like i'd been through so
much that
um
there was no you know i just felt there
wasn't
a human shouldn't
suffer that much
yeah so i decided to do something about
it you know and that that was i never
realized i had adhd until three years
ago you know i need it
and um you know getting that diagnosed i
was like okay that that makes a lot of
sense in terms of
the way i react to noises and pressure
and
you know i'm not good at
i'm not good with people or
you know i work well under pressure i
need lists i need a
you know
i can't deviate from a plan i you know i
try to control everything and
you know even now like today's i'll get
up at [ __ ] 3am and make a cake and
then i'll drink 10 coffees and go and
paint for an hour and then the kids get
you know it's like
i do feel superhuman with it but there's
there comes a very
uh very dark side to that too you know
yeah what do you what do you do with
that because i i deal with that too
where i'm just overwhelmed i can't you
know when you say you have a plan you
have to stick to that plan when somebody
goes well what if we do this i'm like
that gives me anxiety wait a minute
you're talking about changing the plan
up so how do you deal with that it's
like you know i t you know i take
something but uh is it something that
you know you have to work on or be
conscious of and then uh yeah
yeah i mean look this is all part of my
issue in terms of
you know there's an element there of of
of control that
i need
to feel safe you know
um
but part of part of of me
not being so sad and and
self-destructive and and
is about letting letting go and trusting
that
all right you know let's see
i haven't got the answers so let's just
see how it plays out because it it
affects everyone around me you know it's
also i'm also aware again to that weird
loop i'm aware that
it's really unattractive and ugly
to be [ __ ] sad all the time and to be
depressed and to want to control things
and want to make people do what i want
to do
oh don't do it like this you'll be
better you'll be happier if you do this
if you
if you listen to what i say you'll be
happy and then i'll be happy
you know it's it's tiring for people to
disaster my partner my lady is
it's it cost me a
marriage you know and it's i
you i i become very aware that it's
it's really [ __ ] ugly and it's really
hard to live with and then that of
course triggers off
why are you with me why are you you know
and that's when you know
as as a
you know someone who has depression and
and other bits and pieces going on
upstairs it's it's
you then start to trigger yourself and
that's when
you know you can really [ __ ] yourself up
yeah